- What?
- [Voiceover] Lady's Brunch.
- Oh, hell yeah.
- Ladies eat this?
- Who eats this thing?
- So, it looks like it's
just a regular cheeseburger
except there's egg, bacon, and of course,
a Krispy Kreme as the bun.
- Let's do this.
- Whoa.
- It tastes pretty much exactly how
you think it would taste.
- It's delicious.
Is it an innovation on
a standard burger? No.
- It looks like a peanut butter sandwich
but there's white on it?
- Is that Marshmallow Fluff?
- This better not be
mayonnaise and peanut butter.
- Whoa. That's not Marshmallow Fluff.
- Is it mayonnaise?
- That's mayonnaise and peanut butter.
- This is mayonnaise?
- It's actually good.
- Better than I thought it would be.
- [Voiceover] When you
first told me Scrapple,
I thought it was going to be a drink.
- It's like trimmings
and stuff. It's fried.
- It smells like meat.
It doesn't have a bad flavor
but it has a really weird texture.
- Just to, it has a winning
formula for human food;
fat, meat, put that on fire,
and you got delicious.
- [Voiceover] So here, we have olive loaf.
- This looks like a cartoon food.
- It's the meat equivalent
of a fruitcake, right?
- I mean, I don't know
why it's just olive.
There should be other
things embedded in it,
like even more meat.
- Oh my God.
- Nope. Definitely no.
- Yeah, it's like really
salty, but I don't hate it.
- I don't know when you would be like,
"Oh, give me olive loaf," as opposed to,
"Give me ham, or give me Spam,
or give me turkey or anything else."
- Olive loaf. It's better than bologna.
- [Voiceover] Oh, are
these Kool-Aid pickles?
- What?
- What the f-
- I hate pickles but I love Kool-Aid.
- Just purely from an
aesthetic standpoint,
this is beautiful.
- Good.
- I've never eaten like
a full pickle before,
like I take one bite and spit it out,
but I'm going to eat this whole pickle.
I bit my tongue. F-
- Better than a normal pickle?
Yeah.